[Music]
this is important milestone 100th
episode coming up what's the episode
gonna be about well that's why we're
here I think first of all we wanted to
celebrate the fact that it took us nine
years to do 100 episodes shows four or
five years I graduated high school in 11
years goes down in history but we have a
special episode sort of a heightened
episode where the gangs in the middle of
a convenience store robbery and each
character has a fantasy about what would
happen if they intervene and how that
would affect the rest of their life and
Max character has this great fight
sequence where the little spoiler alerts
but he actually dies at the end of it
and he goes to heaven and we get to see
max version of heaven I like it I like
it this is a little spoiler guys guys so
say what whatever it may be slightly
ambiguous we'll see if you can pick up
on it right yeah right great let's take
a look at this clip this is max fantasy
hundred episodes take a look
[Music]
[Music]
god
hello man those were some pretty sweet
moves
thank you my lord seniors will you join
me see to me you goddamn right
oh hey Rex bro so what do we do now now
we ignore everyone's prayers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Mack may be a little bit confused he
might be a little kid doing one more
season than what what we're gonna see
how far we can stretch this thing out
you know we're gonna go out with a
whimper we don't want to go out with a
bang we we might do more we're
definitely we're gonna do season 10 and
then and then we'll see how many you get
on television we talked about this funny
we talked about this last week are you
guys watching that show it's crazy
20 years it was chose it's been 20 years
now right years that's not nine of your
seasons yeah well do do you feel as
though you know do you sit around me
like I've worked too much you know or
you're like happy to have a job that's
sort of my philosophy with doing the
show which where's like I don't want to
not have a job you know it's great Andy
Richter has it so good because I'll get
in my head sometimes if we have if you
know that I don't feel like the material
today and I get it all in my head and
he's he'll always just like hit me on
the shoulder kind of hard actually and
then he's just like it's a job he says
and it's a really great job and I'm like
he's right it's the best job ever and
that's when you kiss then we kiss
[Applause]
he doesn't hit my arm